what does it take to turn cenobites
against each other perhaps even
pinhead's loyal chatterer isn't immune
to betrayal the horrifying cenobite
known as chatterer has been a part of
the Hellraiser franchise since the very
beginning even though he was not
referred to by that name the demon was
featured in The novella that introduced
the cenobites the Hellbound Heart author
Clive Barker's description is very close
to how a character would appear in his
own film adaptation its features were so
heavily scarified the wounds nurtured
until they ballooned and its eyes were
invisible and its words corrupted by the
disfigurement of its mouth one major
difference between the original fiction
and the film adaptation is that
chatterer could actually speak at first
though most likely he was hard to
understand in the films and Comics The
Creature only communicates through the
rather disturbing trademark of clicking
his exposed teeth together instead of
spewing out garbled sentences
in the first Hellraiser film in its
sequel chatterer was played by Nicholas
Vince who made a screen debut with the
role according to Paul Kane author of
The Hellraiser films and their legacy
Vince was a drama student enrolled at
Mount View theater School in London when
he met Clive Barker one of Vince's
classmates was Simon Bamford who was a
member of Barker's theater group the dog
company Bamford would later accept a
role as one of the cenobites and it was
through him that Vince met Parker at a
party which led to a discussion about
working together shortly after in an
interview with Devolution magazine Vince
briefly describes his working
relationship with Parker during the
years leading up to the production of
the iconic horror flick I ended up
modeling for the covers of books of
blood and I think I'm on four out of six
even my head or bits of my body so Clive
had known me for nearly three years by
the time Hellraiser came about he knew I
could do physical stuff so he said would
you like to be in a movie there was some
makeup involved as it turned out that
was something of an understatement
box
it we came
almost nothing is known about chatterer
until the second film Hellbound
Hellraiser 2 which features a brief
glimpse of what the creature looked like
as a human before his horrific
transformation after the film's evil
doctor antagonist mutates into the
powerful chattered cenobite he faces off
against Pinhead and his demon followers
including chatterer even though
chattered is outnumbered he slays each
foe which reveals their past forms
that's when we see chatterer as a young
boy when talking with Devolution
magazine actor Nicholas Vince admitted
he was upset at first about the way that
scene was captured on film but as he
fleshed out his own backstory for the
character he became more intrigued by
the concept of a child cenobite he said
I realized I was really pissed off that
the moment chatterbird changes you
didn't get to see me you got to see a
boy over the years I found the idea of a
boy growing up in Hell fascinating all
the other Santa bites are revealed to be
adults but a boy that whole idea was
really interesting once chatterer had
become a member of pinhead's Entourage
one of his early victims was the
celebrity Janice Bower in the short
story losing herself in the Park from
Clyde Barker's Hellraiser number eight
the actor rejects a role offered by
director Stephen Sigourney because she
cannot relate to the level of pain her
character has gone through in response
Sigourney hands are the lament
configuration and asks her to carry out
an acting exercise with it by getting
the puzzle box into the shape of pain
intrigued by this new method she takes
the Box home and works on it right away
virus Fascination turns dark quickly as
she cuts her hands for days to solve the
puzzle she also begins to have vivid
nightmares of Hell her descent into
madness made her feel ready to accept
the part but that's when the lament
configuration opens and sends the
actress into hell there she is tortured
by chatterer and the other cenobites
while Sigourney films it all power then
continues to act in films but her life
is dominated by The Creatures of Hell
from then on
and Hellraiser Nightbreed Jihad number
one and number two the cenobites
initially confront the Nightbreed in an
epic crossover showdown between two of
Clyde Barker's most popular universes
however before long it becomes clear
that the Alice store and the cenobite
Waging War on the night breed intends to
carry out a complete Purge of his foe
which defies leviathan's will in
response the god of pain and pleasure
orders chatterer and Pinhead to destroy
the heretic and his followers when the
Demonic Warriors encounter Alistar and
his cenobite Entourage he's quickly
abandoned by all his followers except
his lover chaukus who is bound to him
with a Golden Chain once a couple is
defeated Leviathan reverts them to their
human bodies and the two are hunted down
by one of the night breed that they had
tried to exterminate Pinhead has several
followers in his demonic crew throughout
the Hellraiser series but chatter is
often depicted as the leader's top
Lieutenant among the cenobites he has
appeared in more Hellraiser films than
any of the others aside from Pinhead so
the character has a prominent spot
within the nightmarish Universe even so
this didn't save him from the cruel
Wrath of his leader you're suffering be
legendary even in Hell well the first
Channeler was killed off in the second
film he was resurrected 20 years later
by Pinhead in Hellraiser comic series
Pinhead himself was revived once the
pillar of souls was fed blood and
Hellraiser 3 hell on Earth so their
Master used the same method to bring
back chatterer in the female cenobite
with Bloodshed on the very spot where
they had met their demise later in the
fifth chapter of Clyde Barker's
Hellraiser Omnibus Pinhead in the
cenobites confront Kirsty cotton again
and have her in their grass yet instead
of taking the heroine out Pinhead traps
his own followers in his chains despite
their pleas he then hands Kirsty and
knife and she uses it to slay the Santa
bite once more
Pinhead may have been directly
responsible for the second death of his
servant and Clyde Barker's Hellraiser
Omnibus but another Tale shows how
chatterer finally achieved gruesome
revenge for the Betrayal over a decade
before Gary tunnicliff directed the 10th
film Hellraiser judgment he released a
short fan flick in 2004 called No More
Souls which could be considered official
Canon for the series The Story takes
place in a distant future after Humanity
has destroyed itself and hell no longer
has any souls to read in desperation
over the depletion of such a valuable
resource Pinhead opens the lament
configuration to sacrifice himself the
cenobites and emerged to slay their
master and shatter her nails pinheads
ripped off face to a torture pillar
signifying his true end